face à la hausse des discours haineux en
ligne les réseaux sociaux s'unissent
facebook youtube et twitter ont pu hier
un accord avec les annonceurs pour mieux
lutter contre les contenus incitant à la
haine
une décision qui intervient après un
mouvement de boycott en réaction alors
laxisme supposé pour la première fois
cet accord et non un ensemble de
définition claire permettant
d'identifier les discours haineux en
ligne et pour en parler nous sommes avec
gabriel robin journaliste et rédacteur
en chef du magazine l'incorrect gabriel
robin bonjour merci d'être en direct sur
rt france à l'heure des règles
uniformiser pour tous les réseaux à
votre avis cet accord commun sera-t-il
plus efficace que les mesures prises
jusqu'ici individuellement par chaque
réseau social ça arrive d'être efficace
mais alors le problème c'est de définir
ce qu'est un discours de haine si vous
voulez ils ont gamme la main sur presque
tout l'expression contemporaine en
matière de politique en matière d'idées
matière de société avec des dérives
majeures avec la possibilité aussi
calmes d'appliquer une forme de censure
préalable maintenant sur la simple
recommandation de leonardo dicaprio et
kim kardashian parce qu'elles cessent
d'utiliser ils cessent d'utiliser
facebook et instagram
moi ça me ça me semble extrêmement
dangereux on l'avait vu en france avec
la loi a bien on le voit aussi avec
votre média qui par exemple sur twitter
être qualifié de médias d'état pour bien
signifier que vous ne seriez pas que
vous n'auriez pas une une ligne
rédactionnelles et une liberté totale
alors que par exemple un média comme j +
qui était aussi un média d'état qatari
ou même france télévisions qu'il m'a
aidé à des tas de la france et c'est pas
du tout un problème ou la bbc n'ont pas
le droit à cette mention justement où se
situe la frontière entre sont sûres et
modération des contenus et 9 ans vous
mais moi je pense qu'il le problème
c'est que en france avant on avait des
critères objectifs sur ce qu'il pouvait
et ne pouvait pas être dit on n'a pas le
droit d'appeler les gens ouverte
on n'a pas le droit de le défendre une
idéologie qui réclame la mort
d'innocents par exemple si le cas de
certaines visions de l'islamisme qui
avait dans l'état islamique des gens qui
appeler au meurtre des mécréants
ça c'est interdit évidemment ça doit
être interdit en revanche aujourd'hui on
le voit explique ping james par exemple
qui est une entreprise privée de lobby
de lobbying sleeping giant considéré que
valeurs actuelles étaient aux médias
diffusant un discours de haine
simplement parce qu'il relayait eric
zemmour qui pourtant est assez regardées
par les français et qui a certainement
sa façon de dire et des idées assez
tranchée mais qui à mon avis de compte
si tu parles discours de haine de même
que certains discours d'extrême gauche
qui peuvent être particulièrement
virulent sur la société ou dire qu'il
faut manifester en cassant n'ont pas à
être censuré
voilà le dérange à titre personnel mais
ça ne relève pas de discours d'un art
ventes chez des choses je trouve
beaucoup plus dangereux sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est de l'harcèlement ciblées
contre les jeunes
on l'a vu avec la ferme il a on a vu
avec avec d'autres aussi pour d'autres
raisons
ça je trouve que c'est beaucoup plus
problématique alors selon la fédération
mondiale des
annonceurs cet accord qui doit définir
correctement les discours haineux
permettra
de mieux les combattre est ce que vous
êtes de cet avis non moi je pense que de
toute façon ce qui est censuré ce qui
est interdit
quand c est borderline ça devient
beaucoup plus attirants en fait pour les
gens qui on sait cette psychologie et
qui seront là déjà attiré par ce
discours là ça ne fait que qu'alimenter
la machine complotistes au lieu de la
combattre
c'est une réponse qui n'est pas
rationnelle c'est une réponse qui est de
l'ordre de l'envi de pénal la réponse
rationnelle c'est de lutter contre les
discours de haine en leur répondant sur
le fond concrètement parler sinon ben
c'est à dire l'arrêt pendant un mois je
veux dire si je suis si je suis à
internet alors si vous dépassez l'appel
à au meurtre si vous préférez une
idéologie en fait qui est criminel cas
dans certains de ses aspects une part
criminal évidemment devait être ceinturé
mais quand c'est eric zemmour si vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec lui voulu
répondre concrètement vous lui dites
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
nous pourquoi censurer et on y arrivera
en arrivera bientôt regarder djika
rowling et subit un gang scène c'est
l'auteur d'harry potter parce qu'elle a
dit elle a dit ces livres sont brûlés en
direct sur les réseaux sociaux ça ça ne
dérange personne
tout simplement parce qu'elle a dit
quelqu'un qui n'ait femmes restent femme
ou un homme habillé en femme n'est pas
une femme elle a le droit comme le plus
absolu ou d'obtenir ce discours ne
semble pas que ça constitue un discours
de m merci beaucoup gabriel robin
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste et
rédacteur en chef du magazine
l'incorrect